el principal objetivo de la visita de
volodimircelénskia Washington asegurarse
el apoyo de Estados Unidos al esfuerzo
bélico de Ucrania y el momento de la
visita no es casual en menos de dos
semanas los republicanos tomarán el
control de la cámara de representantes
mucho menos entusiastas que los
demócratas a la hora de apoyar a Ucrania
algo que el presidente entrante de la
cámara insinuó antes de las elecciones
de noviembre creo que la gente va a
estar en plena recesión Y no van a
extender un cheque en blanco a Ucrania
Simplemente no lo harán no es un cheque
en blanco gratis el partido de mccarthy
estará ahora en condiciones de limitar
los fondos destinados a Ucrania la
cámara baja del Congreso tiene la última
palabra en áreas clave como defensa
presupuesto y relaciones exteriores y
ejerce de vigilante del poder ejecutivo
si percibe despilfarro de fondos o abuso
de poder y los republicanos tienen toda
la intención de vigilar el presupuesto
como demostró en noviembre una
resolución de la congresista de extrema
derecha Marjorie Taylor Green
el pueblo estadounidense los
contribuyentes de este país merecen
saber a dónde va su dinero y cómo se
gasta 44 mil millones son para ayuda a
Ucrania y otros países afectados Pero
qué otros países Cómo se ven afectados
pero a pesar de los obstáculos que se
avecinan la administración biden ha
prometido que seguirá apoyando a kiev
algo que incluye el desarrollo de
programas de formación para soldados
ucranianos una forma de hacer
seguimiento de los suministros de armas
y darle así seguridad en cierto modo a
los republicanos